my name is elizabeth um i'm one of the
co-founders at deepnote and the title of
my talk is notebooks got your modern
data back
um it was supposed to be a pun i was
told it's not a very good one after i
submitted it so we're just going to go
with it
so i have kind of three things i want to
share with you today um my first
objective is to convince you that data
science notebooks are purple
second
i want to talk about
best practices for working notebooks if
your team uses jupiter notebooks or any
other implementation i'm going to talk
about how you can use that on your team
in a more effective way
and lastly we're going to take a look
under the hood of deep note so at deep
note we're building the next generation
notebook i'm going to show you kind of
some of the design concentration and
principles that are actually
collaborative
so let's start here this is
an abstraction of the modern data stack
that we all know in some shape or form
we're going from the
data sources on the left all the way to
the bi analytics bucket on the right and
so while there are certain principles
and best practices at the back of the
data stack and even some forming in the
middle like decoupling of the metrics
layer from the bi into the middle
the bi analytics bucket actually
contains a lot of different tools
underneath and underneath that there's
some of that
so
what we end up with is a bunch of bi and
analytics tools on one hand
and a bunch of personas on the other one
and these tools are not persona based so
while there are skill dichotomies
this is what happens
on one side this is great because there
is no single perfect tool for every
single use case um and it's good that we
kind of use different tools for
different use cases
on the other hand we are actually
missing out on a lot of shared context
and organizational knowledge in the
space in between
so the question is how do we retain and
how do we share this knowledge
i didn't have a good way to talk about
this for the longest time
until this article came out by by anna
felipe last year um where she's talking
about this notion of purple people
um so the the metaphor she's making is
that you have the blue people who are
people wearing the tech hat and that
there are some red people who are the
business people who are let's say data
consumers
and when you combine these two um
there's a rare breed called purple
people and purple people while they're
not subject matter experts or these like
t-shaped analysts um they can sort of
move on this generalist level they can
take the problem at hand and find the
right tool to solve that problem
so i actually believe that there's
purple people
in different parts of the business
they currently worked in a fairly siloed
way
what we can do is really
create
a hole that's larger than the sum of its
parts if we can bring this together
and i believe that notebooks can help us
actually create this shared
organizational context
why do i think that
so
if you think about
notebook as a paradigm um
it's actually something that's
explainable and transparent it combines
the narrative of your analysis in
markdown it gives you the logic for your
analysis in code and that it has visuals
and insights on the output
so by the general design of the medium
it is explainable and transparent it can
create this shared context it can be
very easily passed on and collaborative
it is also a general purpose medium like
it's currently being served for use for
so many use cases all the way from like
model prototyping model training um
analysis reports prototyping pipelines
data warehouse exploration it's already
being used for such a wide
breadth of use cases by different
personas
and so you might think you know we all
know that notebooks are wonderful in the
single player mode they are amazing for
the
exploratory programming use cases but
how can we actually use them
collaboratively
so a deep note
as a team we've worked with and at a
bunch of data teams across companies
like volunteer google mozilla mckinsey
and so what we came up with is a set of
couple of principles inherited from the
software engineering world that i
believe can really help you um in the
notebooks sort of world as your team
skills
so the first principle is to follow
establish software practices
to write code write documentation write
tests
this might be obvious but this is
something that we should really learn
from the world of um the software
engineering it leads to explainability
and transparency of your analysis
second
logging experiment automatically so
if you do have to do this manually
you're not going to do it anyway
if you automate this practice of
experiment logging you have a much
better view of experimentation that has
happened it's much easier to share and
create a chart context
here you can use tools like comment ml
run ai
weights and biases
next is to split your development and
production environment
this again might be pretty obvious but
if you want to kind of work
collaboratively and efficiently as a
team
it is important to give your team a
permission and full confidence to
experiment and even to fail
what happens is that if you take
there's this asterisk kill here which
has sanitized your user data if you just
fork your production environment and
make it your development environment
there still might be pii passwords um
that your team might not be comfortable
using so do that
for parametrizy or notebooks um this is
really a step towards effective
collaboration the person coming after
you can easily see the inputs the levers
they can pick up and change
and the outcome is easy handover of your
analysis reusability of your notebooks
lastly continuous integration again
a very established practice in the
software engineering world
so when you ship an incremental change
to your users to these stakeholders you
have to make sure your notebooks are
reproducible can they run from the top
to bottom
without breaking without breaking the
workflow
so
you might think you know these are all
great
maybe even obvious
but they're all like pretty blue
practices
um
so we saw deep not we saw this inherent
potential of notebooks
for the purple people and for the purple
world
so we decided to really double down
on focusing on this blue persona we
wanted to create a really really
powerful flexible interface for the
power user while also reducing the
barrier for the red user
we are obviously standing on the
shoulders of giants here like well from
alpha and jupiter notebooks but how can
we really double down and make notebooks
really purple
so easy enough um we start with a blue
in deep note we have implemented
language interoperability what that
means is that you can directly tap into
your snowflake redshave database you can
query your data with sql um save them
into variables in python and use that in
your analysis you can also bring in your
our kernel your julia scala whatever
you're using we want the interface to be
flexible and helpful to meet you where
you are
on to my next point integrations again
very same story um we want to play nice
with
your stack
you might be a data team of two you
might be a fully fledged company oh
what happened
thank you okay cool
yeah so integration so we integrate with
all that that you've seen on the slide
before and more um code intelligence uh
this is again allowing the idea of uh
building and writing clean code that can
be then moved into production so in deep
node we have things like autocomplete
and linting
and you cannot see my slides again
sure thank you
no
sure
is this counting towards my limit
yay thank you
um
was i talking about this called
intelligence okay cool um yes linting
autocomplete
just you're writing cleaner code that's
ready for production
next
mix in the red so here we thought about
what are the things that really help us
bake in the empathy for the data
consumer for the business user
reactivity um a common complaint of
notebooks is this out of order execution
meaning that the outputs of your
notebook don't match the logic and the
linear flow of the notebook so if i'm a
newbie to notebooks this might be really
intuitive and can trip me over so what
we've baked in is this reactivity um
reactive execution which ensures that
the output of your notebook is always
consistent with the actual state so if
you change your input
the output um and all the cells that
pertain to it downstream change
dynamically
cmos editing we think there's no reason
for business people to have to know how
to write markdown to be able to
accomplish something in notebooks so we
have this
premise of what you see is what you get
same editing experience as you would
have in like google docs or
anything else really
data apps um
we started out by actually doing
something where we like gave users the
opportunity to hide cells um but we
found that the users some of the users
like execs were still not comfortable
coming into that space and sort of um
digesting those outputs in that way so
what you see on the screen is on your
left you have the notebook on the right
you have this sort of canvas where
you're picking and choosing cells that
you want to move into your data app and
these are not programs let's say it runs
on schedule every morning um
it also dynamically propagates to the
actual published report so that your
stakeholders have this fresh
data app updated
cool and that brings us to purple so
what are the things that enable those
folks who might be red
and those folks who might be skewing
right
blue to kind of come together and learn
from each other
collaboration is an obvious one i don't
have to talk about this um
we have a real-time collaboration in the
same way that you would experience in
google docs the same way you would
experience it in figma or anything else
we obviously also have asynchronous
collaboration
which is done through comments
and knowledge organization this is a big
one because um i was talking about this
at the beginning how do we then take all
that learning and enable people to learn
from each other and sort of to
cross-pollinate so folders is what we
have for knowledge organization then on
the top of that we're building access
rights so that you can make sure that
appropriate people are seeing and doing
the appropriate things in this
environment so our workspaces you know
you can bring in your exec who can only
have viewing rights you can have your pm
come in and give comments and maybe your
scientists to give subject matter input
um you can have your analysts in sort of
editing um mode
and then templates it's really easy to
fork projects of others so if i fork a
project of my colleague i inherit all
the dependencies all the integrations
all the data sets the docker
environments i can just like get
straight to work
so that's where we are
you might ask you know what does this
purple world look like
and i wanted to share a case study of
one of our customers guesto so deepnode
is already being used at hundreds of
organizations castle being one of them
um we actually have multiple teams
across the organization using us all the
way from data science to
people analytics which is this story
here so what we're seeing here is we had
the people team so the hr and recreators
using tableau and google drive analysts
using excel and rstudio and then exacts
only digesting outputs um through
powerpoint
and this is the world we're hoping to
build and that we're already seeing
developing at gusto
so what happened is that deep node sort
of became the center of gravity for all
the data conversations your data
engineers give you the credentials to
connect into your data warehouses um you
as an analyst don't need to build
complex pipelines you can do easy
scheduling jobs in deep note
automatically if you want to build data
apps you can totally do that but again
we have to meet the red people where
they are so if you wanna just export um
things um into things like tableau or
google drive you're absolutely you can
absolutely do that and so the change
we're seeing is that
analysts can actually focus on more high
order problems
and people are comfortable coming into
notebooks and having that conversation
right there at that place
these are the outcomes
streamlined workflows
um reduce time to insight by breaking
down the silos and views of purple
everywhere
um so i think i'm on time
thank you
[Applause]